es una de las mayores victorias de los
republicanos ron de santis ganó por
segunda vez en la gobernación de Florida
con 20 puntos de diferencia y
perfilándose para la presidencia lo que
muchos ven como una alternativa Donald
Trump para las presidenciales de 2024
solo acabo de empezar a luchar que Dios
los bendiga a todos Muchas gracias
gracias por una victoria histórica y
aplastante
Además del control del senado 36
gobernaciones estaban en juego en una
carrera muy reñida otra de las caras
conservadoras más visibles Drake abbot
repetirá como gobernador por tercera vez
en Texas juntos haremos que Texas siga
siendo el mejor estado del mejor país en
la historia de todo el mundo los
demócratas consiguieron victorias clave
en el llamado muro azul Michigan
Wisconsin y Pensilvania estados clave
para la elección de biden en 2020 con la
victoria de josha firo en este último
estado en lo que parece ser un fracaso
de los candidatos apoyados por Donald
Trump en la región
la libertad real prevaleció en
Pensilvania me siento honrado y
orgulloso de ser su próximo gobernador
con el retorno de Trump como telón de
fondo en Georgia los republicanos
mantuvieron la gobernación con Brian un
candidato alejado del ex presidente Y es
que lejos de la marea roja que se había
predicho los demócratas han conseguido
tomar delantera en las gobernaciones
tras arrebatar a Maryland con el primer
gobernador afroamericano y Massachusetts
con la primera gobernadora lesbiana
mientras Dios se ha gobernadora las
mujeres siempre tendrán Libertad para
controlar sus propios cuerpos nuestro
estado proporcionará acceso seguro y
legal al aborto
[Aplausos]
y consolidar California y Nueva York
entre otros con unas elecciones de medio
término que dejan un escenario incierto
de Cara a las elecciones de 2024 con un
país muy dividido y polarizado